[Laughter]
[Music]
what's happening you bad mother [__]
this uncle Joey here in full [__]
effect especially time with the baby
this morning at the park went to jujitsu
did a little riding now man with you
[__] for UFC to old to you bad
[__] you beating up on the man
you putting the man Hospital
how come on I see no bruises on you cuz
I'm a [__] karate man [__]
and karate man don't bruise on the other
side you a big very white looking
[__] you know saying what's
happening three different types of weeds
we got the Paris go perennial we got the
[__] ghost OG spooking [__]
to death and we got the [__] rascal
og Italian that's leading the [__]
Valley perenial if you ain't going there
you're [__] slipping I'm saying
I love it a little marijuana before the
[__] fights to put your head where
you [__] belong understand nice a
little rascal now you see what that's
all of them
[__] tremendous you understand room
nice fight tonight
you got Anthony Bronco you got cowboy
Rick's glory
you've got Diaz and that's my [__]
man you know we got some [__] blast
here tonight people gonna be bitching
you asking Joey you're gonna bet I pay a
little while you know I'm saying I got a
one pink I'm gonna [__] slam I
already caught the guy I'm waiting for
him to call me back and that's it
all you need is one [__] pick and go
to bed what I'm giving you today
understand
sometimes you got to switch up writers
that's why you always gotta have three
for [__] lightly say you got some good
ones
we have these portable can you make the
best of what you got and that's it it's
[__] Saturday it's fight day you got
your wins your hummus you got your
[__] sty mean can juice you're ready
to [__] go you understand me all you
need now is your uncle [__] Joey
and I said we're here what the [__] else
you want
Clemence BC moths I love to smell a
brief from the [__] morning and the
standing nice I got up at 7:00 Claire I
hit that [__] pipe I had my [__]
CBD oil my little [__] what do you
call that [__] my little Harman smoothie
with [__] milk milk smoothie with
[__] fruit and I'm ready to go you
know say I'm trying guys I'm trying I'm
a fat [__] but I'm trying the whole
thing is you lose the [__] weight me
your head still stays [__] huge so to
the size of his [__] battering ram on
my head but what are you gonna do on my
handsome [__] I love this smell
of [__] reefer gonna give some
shoutouts come on man Timmy Holloway jr.
[__] over there Secaucus running
[__] off the street
my man waterboxx I haven't seen all
[__] week hope you Spooky's close by
we got our pigs [__] you
understand me we wrote deep like the
DA's [__] plan stone that like it I
don't even know what the [__] I'm late
that I don't think about we'll chop
salad maybe
with some making a little blue cheese so
we did the rascal
right we did the ghost right what's left
we did the [__] ghost we did the
perennial I don't even know let's just
smoke another boat with family it all
goes to the same spot under the
understanding sometimes you mix the we
each and I'll know what the [__] it
would I think it's time to go smoke
let's try this [__] ghost
this isn't a call for three days I just
left the minute he understand by the
time I got for the car hate was like two
[__] grams you'd be hydrated but now
I got that [__] that I got Godzilla
dandruff II understand there's the [__]
for [__] Japanese people smart before
they pull stars and jump backward to the
raw fish
oh that's too much that's what happens
when you first break it up door comes up
and [__] luck I got to be prepared
for this [__] next time
stars on the way please dropping them
off that's it man I make this easy I
make my my people in money why aren't
you in the fight sitting behind Joe
smoking the vapor well I would like to
you a [__] Momo I'm at home with my
feet up my Songhai toe is breathing I'm
in the Kurdish in my own [__] Mikasa
I got unlimited weed and get up when I
want I can take this [__] I don't wanna
walk up twenty two flights of [__]
stairs I got people hanging I'm gonna
watch the fight and I got the picture do
you I'm glad look like I wanted
something take a picture right now got
something I don't wanna take no [__]
pictures I'm gonna install them sitting
here nothing a picture can take a
picture like a [__] piggies gonna
change your [__] life you're still
gonna be a half a month when you get the
way you're gonna look at me with the
[__] man are you [__] crazy
I don't take pictures that no matter
what no because of me I never want a
picture of me out there look at his
[__] face you want a picture like
this out there who are you kidding
[__] uncle joey's i handsome
[__] check see what happens when I
smoke grief will you [__] to see
what you do to me get me on [__]
robots and crazy I don't need this [__]
this is all this is it you want a drink
you want to do your [__] ecstasy head
I should get the [__] out of here
listen Michael on the road I took listen
this is old reliable this works [__]
one this one and nobody gets hurt
nobody gets kidnapped nobody gets a
bitch-slap you don't owe nobody nothing
you just smoke [__] reason yeah I'm
saying that's it
you get stoned the worst that could
happen is you eat a bag of [__] chips
or an apple or something like that
that's it that's the worst NECA [__]
it's very nice that you people join me
for these [__] balls both lost it
what are the [__] Savage that you
know besides uncle Joey let the ping
goes off I show up we'll reach the smoke
everybody else shows up for the [__]
story
what they gonna do and pictures of their
[__] lunch who gives a [__] we show
up smoking weed with a big dick and a
[__] I don't even know no mom I'm out
of [__] we said I'm gonna cinema
synonyms whatever [__]
we think one more [__] doozy let's do
it
look at the eye book as the eyeball of
death right there what are you [__]
nuts that's 20 alive no [__] parole
that I bought let's do a ghost let's do
what do you think this is golf not let's
do I'm over here playing [__]
three-card Monte by myself which one do
I smoke I don't [__] know jelly which
one just a [__] parade
let's want to do listen perennial as
this [__] homegrown we think that
they take that home growth but they grow
their own brand and their make up their
own seed and it's a perennial old cheap
it's a invitar PR you know what that
means PR anyway to me Porto Ricans it
means your [__] rot they come in a
thousand [__] things but PR to these
[__] Gentiles means Private Reserve
whatever that means listen just give me
this [__] that to kill [__]
Frankenstein that's all right it's
optimal and your lungs listen if this
[__] don't burn I don't [__] want it
understand me
you have to drink kombucha juice when
you do bong it's looking drink the
computer juice that comes out of my
[__] kombucha dick
kombucha juice I should good though and
you're taking antibiotics so you're
eating [__] oxy so whatever the [__]
you doing it's bedtime if there's a
little compulsion juice
it keeps the [__] [__] alive in your
stomach and I'm saying you [__] think
you tell me I don't think I know about
this [__] I'm a man of a thousand
occupations
I'm a man of many weeks and a man of
many occupations you understand me and
that's all you need to [__] know my
smoking medical marijuana I smoke
medical and medical medicalized or
medicalized rationalised
rap you know I smoked marijuana from all
over the [__] world
well that's it that's that got [__] to
do and people to [__] to see I've
already been smoking with you
[__] for my 20 minutes I said I
had a tap that's it I'm gonna how many
more [__] magnets can we do how much
more she can go into my [__] lungs
I'll be checking in with you [__]
throughout the night after the fighting
like the real cards fire I should be
doing people to see after that we'll do
a couple [__] little things we'll
smoke some more weed some [__] stars
together we'll get this party started
that's it that's that all right I love
you [__] you know I love you
nobody else does this [__] with you
nobody else comes out of the house
leaves this beautiful [__] cats and
the baby and his wife the come on hand
smoke with you [__] you know
who does uncle [__] Joey that's
that's what why do you think what do you
think cuz I know Miami and I love you
both for did you [__] on the [__]
bomb
don't do you [__] latest a
black boy you will do another touch
alerts and we'll get the [__] pics
out and let you know what's going on
this light afternoon with Joey all right
we'll do late for these but don't show
up and no [__] reason I don't want
talk I don't like people smoke with no
[__] Christmas already if you're
under 18 hang up now no [__] look
who's gonna comment but one of the [__]
you do your time stay polite uncle Joey
loves you [__]